die vorstellung dass krieg damit militär
und unter einsatz von militärischer
waffengewalt geführt werden kann ist in
manchen bereichen bereits überholt
moderne technologien erlauben es staaten
aber auch nicht staatlichen akteuren
massiven druck auf den gegner auszuüben
wir sehen dem zeitalter der übrigen
bedrohungen angekommen
[Musik]
kurz zu den begriffen hybrid war für
hybride kriegführung es halt ein sehr
inflationärer ausdruck der darauf
verweist dass das primär das militär zum
einsatz kommt militärische mittel
ich ziehe daher eher den anderen
ausdruck für hybride bedrohung was
versteht man darunter übrigen bedrohung
ist der akkordierte einsatz aller
verfügbaren methoden mittel und
instrumente um druck auf einen
opponenten auf einen anderen staat
auszuüben
das ziel dabei ist sein verhalten zu
ändern ihn zu schaden vielleicht sogar
ihn zu destabilisieren mit den neuen
möglichkeiten mit den neuen techniken
internet digitalisierung künstliche
intelligenz sind hier völlig neue
möglichkeiten entstanden ein altes
phänomen erscheint daher in neuer form
was sind nun die merkmale einer hybriden
bedrohung ganz wichtig es handelt sich
um ein verdecktes vorgehen es kann aber
auch offen erfolgen
wir haben staatliche akteure aber auch
nichtstaatliche akteure in staat kann
sich auch eine hacker-gruppe zb bedienen
und wir selber attacken durchzuführen
hier haben wir einen legalen bereich
einen illegalen bereich und einen
graubereich rechtlich ist vieles nicht
genau definiert und wir haben ein
wesentliches element das sind viele
instrumente die beliebig kombinierbar
sind
und das alles kann als dass die
überraschend ohne irgendeine ankündigung
erfolgen
und das ist die neue qualität diese neue
herausforderung der übrigen bedrohung
zur veranschaulichung ein kleines
konstruiertes beispiel stadt möchte auf
staat druck ausüben wie kann etwas
machen
ganz wichtig die nutzung oder eigentlich
der missbrauch von medien fake news ein
probates mittel um einfluss auf den
wahlkampf zu nehmen
auch zwischenstaatliche irritationen
hervorzurufen heuer im sommer ganz
massiv zwischen katar und saudi arabien
cyberattacken österreich ist dafür auch
nicht gefeit wir hatten letztes jahr
eine massive attacke auf dem flughafen
schwechat auf die nationalbank aber
viele andere stellen dritter bereich
wirtschaft energie finanzwesen hier ist
es möglich finanzspekulationen zu machen
eine währung unter druck zu bringen man
kann aber auch den finanztransfer
stoppen womit die zahlungsfähigkeit
eines landes ist einfach nicht mehr
gewährleistet dies daher ganz massiv
möglichkeit hier druck auszuüben unter
vierte bereich ist diplomatische und
politische maßnahmen man kann einen
start von verhandlungen ausschließen man
kann eine stadt diskreditieren
man kann versuchen gegen inso stimmung
zu machen dass er wirklich unter druck
gerät
das ist aber noch nicht alles starter
kann auch versuchen im inneren vom staat
b zu wirken zum beispiel indem er
bestimmte gruppierungen fördert das
können politische oppositionsparteien
sehen dass keine radikale elemente seien
das können auch minderheiten seien die
hier einfach für unruhe sorgen in diesem
land und zuletzt militärische mittel
hier haben wir die dimension von außen
wo man mit manövern zum beispiel
drohkulissen darstellen kann aber auch
im inneren wesentlich subtiler in dem
nachrichtendienstliche kräfte am werk
sind in dem man schläfer platziert in
denen radikale elemente bewaffnet und
derlei gibt es noch viel viel mehr
all das führt dazu dass wirklich druck
auf einen start ausgeübt werden kann
dass sie eingeschüchtert werden kann
dass er isoliert werden kann und
vielleicht sein verhalten ändert oder
pest avisiert wird
was kann man nun gegen diese hybriden
bedrohungen machen was ist zu tun
es ist völlig falsch hier eine taxi
tiefe aufzählung zu machen weil es so
vielfältig ist aber drei bereiche kann
man ansprechen das eine ist eine
bewusstseinsbildung wir müssen uns
dessen bewusst sein wie umfassend diese
bedrohung sein kann wie vielfältig sie
sein kann
damit wir uns ernsthaft damit
auseinandersetzen können das zweite ist
eine hybride bedrohung erfordert eine
hybride antwort als eine umfassende und
das heißt zivile und nicht zivile
militärisch nicht mit
maßnahmen und instrumente hier mitdenken
um zu einem entsprechenden spektrum an
gegenmaßnahmen zu kommen
drittens ein staat alleine kann das
überhaupt nicht erledigen internationale
kooperation intensive zusammenarbeit ist
hier erforderlich letztlich soll
resilienz erzeugt werden also eine
widerstandsfähigkeit gegenüber diesen
bedrohungen und eine antwort fähigkeit
was bedeutet das nun für österreich wie
gehen wir damit um über die bedrohungen
sind ein globales phänomen jeder staat
hat seine antworten zu finden aus
österreichischer sicht ist es sehr
wichtig hier ein früherkennung sind
frühwarnsystem zu haben und andererseits
sagen antwort system zu haben dass die
erforderliche resilienz verleiht beide
es geht nur gesamtstaatlich und der
einsatz und vernetzung aller zivilen und
militärischen mittel die verfügbar sind
im serverbereich geht der trend
eindeutig in richtung jugend hier setzt
man auf die jugend das ist in israel so
dass es in österreich so dass ich in
allen anderen staaten auch so aber
eigentlich geht es darum sicherheit und
verteidigung neu zu denken angesichts
dieser hybriden bedrohungen das ist die
große herausforderung der müssen wir uns
stellen und bei der beantwortung wird
das bundesheer sicher eine entscheidende
rolle spielen
[Musik]